the crisis at our Southern border
hitting new records CBP revealing
illegal encounters surpassed 300,000 in
December alone meanwhile the showdown
escalates between Texas and the White
House over razor wire as Governor Abbott
asserts his State's right to defend
itself but the Lone Star State is not
alone 25 Governors now supporting Abbot
in the fight Georgia Governor Brian kimp
is one of them and he joins us now
Governor km thanks for being with us why
did you think it was important for
Georgia to join
Texas well good morning guys thanks for
having me on listen it's like you know
Governors all over the country been
saying every State's a border state now
that includes Georgia and that's why
we're standing strong with Governor abot
to stop this Insanity at the southern
border because the president and the
White House
won't so Governor what do you think is
going on with the B Administration right
now A record number over
300,000 illegal immigrants in the month
of December alone they've been in the
Biden has been in the administration for
almost a full term now do you think they
they don't care they don't recognize
this problem or do they think that this
is a political calculation fighting
Texas will somehow help them in their
reelection
effort well I think early on they just
didn't care um now I think they just you
know and and I think a lot of people
thought they didn't get it I think now
they're seeing the political
ramifications of that which is insane
when you think about over
300,000 Encounters in December that
breaks a September record so the
problems getting worse not better uh 19
people on the FBI Terror watch list were
arrested uh for a total of 50 this
fiscal year I mean how many of those
have gotten through that we didn't
apprehend that are now in our country so
these are serious things I think the
American people are ready for the
president to do something and you know
the White House yesterday in response to
the uh Republican Governors that are
standing with Governor Abbot sent a
letter you know they're saying call your
member of Congress and get them to work
out a deal I mean look this buck stops
with the White House and President Biden
he had both houses of Congress from 2020
to 2022 and didn't do a damn thing about
the crisis at the border and now that
it's gotten political they're trying to
lay the blame on somebody else this is
actions that the president can take
today to turn this tide and stand with
Governor Abbott instead of working
against him governor should uh speaking
of the administrations uh you know right
now Donald Trump's running to be the the
next Commander in Chief to be the person
enforcing what's going on at the border
just turn to shift shift gears just a
little bit uh what do you make of the
state of the Republican race night now
on the Republican side cuz there's two
candidates left some people are saying
uh there's not enough delegates to be
had for Nikki Haley where are you on the
on on whether this race should continue
or
not well I think when you look at the
delegate count I know somebody in
Georgia tweeted yesterday that you know
uh less people have voted in this
election than residing Gwynette County
Georgia so you know two strong wins no
doubt about it early on but still a long
way to go and I I don't think it's for
you know the party leadership or anybody
else decide who the nominee is going to
be that's that's a there's a process for
that the people will vote and decide
that and I know the candidates have to
decide you know when's the right time
for them to exit uh a race if they're
going to uh so I'll leave that up to
them I think we'll continue to watch got
a long way to go to South Carolina um
but look that that doesn't change the
fact of the matter that everybody's
standing on the Republican side in
solidarity with what's happening in
Texas the disaster at the southern
border The Runaway inflation we've seen
in the country just the bad policies of
the white house really to have people so
fired up about this election 2024 is
going to be a critical
Year all right Governor Brian Kim thanks
for being on standing with Texas
governor thank you so much for joining
us I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis